from Big noon kickoff on Fox Sports is
former I'd once a golden dome are always
a golden dome or Brady Quinn how are you
Brady I'm doing well thanks for having
me out man you can rest after that game
last night you know what I'll tell you I
live on the left coast so I got to sleep
decent long time I have no idea how
people on the East Coast handle it those
does the the game lasts just in an
eternity and Brady Quinn kind enough to
call in right here from Fox Sports part
of the Honda inside a report on the Rich
Eisen show I'll give you the floor I
mentioned off the top of the show
Joe borrowed just set the bar for any
human being that wants to play college
football quarterback from here on out
that's that's the Bardis that's the bar
to try and leap over greatest season in
the history of that position in the
sport your thoughts yeah I don't think
it's hyperbole I think it's the truth I
think with what she did to get to that
point the way he dominated he never
flinched he never had four months or
even average performance and especially
versus all the different top ten
opponents all the tests along the way I
I'll go further than just saying for a
quarterback I just think it was the
single greatest performance we've seen
from any college football player just
dominance from the start to the
beginning and if it probably makes a
little bit sweeter to considering his
story in his journey and how he got to
this point yeah because he wasn't you
know the the nine star recruit that got
fought over by 15 programs and he you
know sat there and with 20 hats in front
of himself on live television and put a
hat on like that that that's not what
happened he's made himself it's a it's a
self-made with obviously the right
system and the right coaching but it's
it's what burns within and belief
himself that's what I love Brady I love
it love all of it I just love in an era
of and granite he was a graduate
transfer quarterback yes but that was
kind of more forced on him in the sense
that he wasn't really gonna get an
opportunity to start and play and when
he did come to LSU initially I mean last
year it was somewhat of an average
season it was kind of your status quo I
think for LSU quarterbacks and what
we've seen within the system and what do
you want to mark it up to the abyss of
joe grady as their passing game corps
the maturation of like all the other
pieces out around or even himself
however the case may be it all came
together just in this historic magical
run for LSU there's no other way of
describing it but but thinking how he
fought through the adversity of going to
the school undergoes dream school out of
state having it not work out and being
able to be open to finding other
opportunities and going in there and
even through again somewhat of an
average season understanding and
believing that he had more they had more
their team had more that story to me
just resonates so it resonates so much I
think with so many people we well we all
expect you know to have the best result
that's our intention but what happens
how do you respond when it doesn't work
out oh it didn't work out at Ohio State
forum it didn't even really worked out
the first year at LSU yet he still kept
his head down continued to keep working
and and I asked me earlier today like
what will I remember most about Joe
burrow this season it's not any one play
in particular it's the fact that his
actions spoke louder than his words you
know his performances or just so God he
liked the way he went about his business
he was so cool about it that I don't
necessarily remember one thing just
because everything I remember was more
about how he carried himself an hour he
conducted himself throughout the entire
year and and probably more than anything
else the iconic picture of him sitting
on a couch smoking a cigar like lent off
that was I'd saw that photograph last
night it's exactly what I thought about
except you know Len did his you smoke in
his heater during halftime of a game you
know a Brady Quinn here on the Rich
Eisen show and then just you know to
complete the conversation with Joe is
the next-level stuff he's already making
next-level throws he's bought receivers
with one step he's finding them with
different throws into those windows
whether it is thrown to the pylon or
thigh pointing for a receiver or
dropping it in a window throwing dimes
or dropping it in buckets he seems to
have all that is it mechanics what is it
with him Brady but that allows them to
do what he's doing here his mechanics
are flawless and I think it stems more
to the fact that he's not a thrower he's
not a guy who you know
probably grew up in those day I was a
coach back in Athens Ohio he's not a guy
that I feel like was was you know
specializing at a young age I think he's
the type of guy that it was a tremendous
basketball player probably would've been
a heck of a college basketball player if
you wanted to go that route and he's
just an overall good athlete you know he
strikes me as the type of guy that no
matter what position or what sport you
gave him you figure it out if you gave
him any type of ball he's figure out how
to throw it and that's more of what his
kind of throwing motion looks like to me
he's just it's athletic it's it's quick
its efficient and then what it needs to
you can change the arm angles you can
change the type of throw and that's
really what a passer is and that's what
makes him so special from the pocket the
thing that stands out to me the most
though is just his pocket movement how
sudden he is how slippery he is while
still maintaining ball security those
are the things that are gonna bode well
for him because look he's going to the
worst team in the NFL it's the
Cincinnati Bengals I granted their
offensive line went through some
injuries they should be healthier next
season but he's gonna face from some
protection issues it's not he's not
gonna have the Joe Moore award-winning
offensive line that he had at LSU so his
pocket movement and his athleticism is
building to run his toughness those are
the things that I think he's going to
need the most early in his career aside
from all the intangibles that come along
with it as a passer Brady Quinn Fox
Sports here in the Rich Eisen show and
so what what what did we learn about
Clemson last night Brady did we learn
anything about about Clemson they just
ran into a buzzsaw what do you got for
me on their PostScript I think you're
taking away the fact that this is the
first time this season and you can do it
back to the North Carolina game and I'll
talk about the honesty in a second but I
don't know that they really felt you
know a sense of urgency like what they
felt last night
you know highest a jumped out to leave
the semifinal game the difference was
they were kind of aided right some calls
went their way after the Shawn Wade
ejection for targeting that gave them a
bit of a lift on that specific Drive in
that point the game takes out one of the
better defensive backs for Ohio State
the catch that looked to me to be a
fumble and then return that took away at
least some points off the board for them
so you know even though and look you
give him credit for coming back in the
game the way they played it wasn't
quite the same like this was one where
Trevor Lawrence and this offense was
gonna have to put up points they were
gonna have to be you know special the
entire night and have one of their best
performances and I just think in the
second half two things that became
pretty apparent the coaching staff they
got away from Travis VTN it was a
3-point good ball game it's a little
less than 11 minutes to play and I think
he touched the ball like one of the time
the rest the rest away I mean really
didn't touch the football much and he's
one of their best players and so I think
they panicked a little bit in that sense
and then with Trevor Lawrence you saw
the number of high throws look he got a
little anxious I think you started to
realize that he was now in a shootout
with the guy across the field from him
and he at plan against Joe burrow
instead of playing against the LSU
defense he started over-striding he
started making some of those throws I
started to fail on him a little bit
that's typically what happens when you
do that so it's a learning experience
for me the true true sophomore he said
so much success I don't worry about him
I don't really worry about Clemson bill
reload for next year and then I wanna
still be my favorite two one next year
well the word schadenfreude is is out
there in terms of people who enjoy the
misery of others when James scowl ski
got ejected for targeting last night and
Clemson's I guess quarterback of the
defense is removed
Ohio State fans that I know were
particularly enjoying that moment I
think they found a little bit of
deliciousness in that moment do you
think that was a a good to call last
night
Brady based on the letter of the law
unfortunately that's what should have
taken place and we can all complain
about targeting and and the way it's
implemented in the game however at this
point you know it's there for player
safety you could tell based on the
replay that he lowered his head and
initiated contact with the crown of his
helmet they're trying to eliminate that
step from the game and yeah I was
sitting with next to Urban Meyer talking
him about the Sean way did and what he
said to me at that moment
look bottom line is you could talk about
how unfair was and how unfair the rule
is but you know everyone knows it now
we're teaching it we're trying to teach
anyone to keep their head up that's all
he had to do and Sean wait
in the Ohio State Clemson game so you
know look should they go back and try to
change the rule for that we can kind of
read into it intent of the hit because I
do think there are differences where you
look at the hit and a semifinal game
between Oklahoma and LSU and that more
looked like a malicious hit and there
was intent behind that by the linebacker
for Oklahoma versus flight Edwards
alaire I believe as compared to Sean
Wade or as compared to the linebacker
last night so it's something that I do
think college football is going to look
at I don't see them you know looking to
change anytime soon though because
ultimately we are getting you know more
you know proper form tackling less these
sorts of hits and injuries and I think
that's really ultimately what we want
Brady Quinn here Fox Sports and then and
then there's the question about college
football writ large Brady where anybody
with a set of eyes could see last night
that that that had what would you say
about half or more than half on the
field certainly for starting NFL talent
that you know we got a text from our
king of spring as we call him at the NFL
Network Charlie Duke who's in charge of
all of our talent evaluation portion of
our coverage of the of the year from
what's going down with east-west Shrine
game all the way through to the draft
hey everybody just watched tonight's
game and you're you're set for the draft
this year and and and and it made sense
what what does that mean does that mean
does that mean we've only got five six
teams that can actually compete for a
national championship college wise
because everybody's gonna have some NFL
talent but not like NFL talent it at in
the depth chart three times over at
every position like we saw what appeared
to be last night Brady no I think the
reality is there's probably eight to ten
teams I mean I don't know if it says as
small as six
look no sticking LSU to win the national
championship for the season were they I
mean so there's so they've gone somewhat
of a historical run and a surprising run
I think we looked at Alabama things
changed when sue I got injured as far as
their fortune you know you looked at
something that seems like Clemson figure
that they were gonna have a clear path
so you know as far as how much towel is
on the field and all that I mean that
that's just where we're at and our
society right like we're looking at
professional sports teams are particular
in the NBA where we're looking at guys
who want to join one another and play
with one another I think it's the same
thing with recruit
you know they see success those teams
are gonna try to recruit based off their
success and then try to entice players
want to be a part of it
and I just think the pitch or the sale
that a come come here and come create
that you know your own legacy or come
here and bring back our program to
prominence like that I don't know that
pitch really resonates with many young
people anymore I think people want to
have success they don't want to have to
necessarily go there and go through some
tough years before they see the other
side and I think it's more of a product
of that at least in regards to all the
talent because when you're looking at
what's on the field a lot of it has to
do with the teams that we see in the
early signing period we're gonna see
coming up for National Signing Day the
teams that tend to be in the top four
talent when recruiting tend to be the
ones that are always wanted for a
national championship and that's just a
product of where we're at in our society
in my opinion and let me go off the
board with you before I let you go Brady
Quinn and the Honda Insight report here
on the Rich Eisen show if somebody was
drafted in the first round by the Miami
Dolphins and then the your career didn't
go as well as you had hoped certainly in
the Miami portion of it what do you
think of Ryan Tannehill what do you
think's going through his mind right now
is he's one playoff went away from going
to Miami in the home of the Dolphins and
winning this Super Bowl and getting a
chance to at least play in it what do
you think of that what do you think's
going through his head right business
history there is I was picking out me a
draft by man he didn't happen ended up
oh that's right my bad well for Ryan
like I could only imagine just from
knowing him a little bit to just ready
to have our shoulder if if he could be
able to you know find his way makes you
know make his way through Arrowhead and
those three kind of big places to play
and go win football games to plan a
Super Bowl they're down in Miami I can
only imagine the emotions that would
come along with it but I think you know
he's more he's more focused on what's at
hand right now considering the task of
they haven't been so great even though
he hasn't asked to do much and he
executed well last week he's going to be
challenged with that this week so I
remember he's looking we all thought you
gonna be drafted by Miami that's right
my right I just bring here III did do
trust me rich III did too and then I
think he's kind of drastically the final
few rounds there or the final few picks
so my bad Brady I just you know I just
say it's interesting though just seeing
what Tannehill can actually do right
here it really is you got a pic in the
and the in this for who makes a super
bowl then before I let you go yeah
Kansas City angry bad I think Kansas
City wins it much like we saw from yeah
yeah I think Green Bay goes into San
Francisco and gets the win I know it it
seems odd because of the way they've won
and they never really went in a
convincing manner but it was a 14 and 3
at this point I just there's something
about that team there's some about Aaron
Rodgers that I trust to be able to find
a way what in that game and ultimately I
said we can't video a party hey Brady
really love watching what you do on Fox
with the college football it's been fun
and what you've what you built for
yourself and I really appreciate the
time here let's let's get you in here in
person and hang out a little bit more
got a Brady you got it that's Brady
Quinn at Brady underscore Quinn on
Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app